>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," WASHINGTON'S MASKED
DELUSION TOUR CONTINUES AND
AMAZING TO WATCH.
HOURS AGO IN THE LATEST
INSTALLMENT OF SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE AND THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEF OF STAFF JEFF HELD A
PRESS CONFERENCE AT THE PENTAGON
AND TOLLING US WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN TELLING US ALL WEEK, THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND EVERYBODY
IN CHARGE.
THEY ARE TELLING US OUR
DEPARTURE FROM AFGHANISTAN, THAT
THIS IS LOAD OFF FROM THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE BEEN A
RESOUNDING SUCCESS.
OF COURSE IF YOU SUBTRACT THE 13
DEAD AMERICANS, THE TWO DOZEN
TRAPPED SCHOOL CHILDREN, THE
AFGHANS FALLING OFF AIRPLANES,
OR THE FACT THAT WE ARMED THE
TALIBAN WITH $90 BILLION WORTH
OF AUTOMATIC WEAPONS AND
HELICOPTERS, IT'S BEEN GREAT.
THEY ARE SAYING THIS SO OFTEN,
HOWEVER, THAT IT MAY NOT BE
PROPAGANDA.
IT IS STARTING TO SEEM LIKE
EVERYONE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY BELIEVES
THEY JUST WON.
THAT MIGHT EXPLAIN WHY THEY ARE
PROMOTING JENNIFER RUBIN COLUMNS
FROM "THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
WALKING AWAY FROM REPORTERS
WITHOUT TAKING ANY QUESTIONS.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN
THEMSELVES.
IT'S OBVIOUS THIS IS A VICTORY.
WATCHING ALL OF THAT SHOULD
WORRY YOU.
THERE ARE ONLY TWO EXPLANATIONS
FOR IT.
EITHER EVERY SENIOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL IN WASHINGTON HAS BEEN
CHUGGING I WALTZED OUT AND
DEPARTED FROM REALITY ON THE
EARLY TRAIN, AND THAT'S
POSSIBLE.
OR ON SOME DEEPER LEVEL, MAY BE
THEY ARE ACTUALLY TELLING THE
TRUTH AS THEY UNDERSTAND IT.
WHEN THEY SAY THIS IS A VICTORY,
MAY BE FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE IT
IS.
MAYBE WHAT LOOKS LIKE CHAOS IS
IN FACT A PLAN OF SORTS, AND
THAT IS WORKING JUST FINE.
HOW CAN THAT BE COMING YOU ASK
IT, THIS IS ALL A CLEAR
DISASTER.
VOTERS HATE IT, THE POLLS SHOW
THAT VERY CLEAR.
DO SO BY ANY NORMAL CALCULATION,
DEMOCRATS WOULD BE VERY WORRIED
ABOUT THE NEXT ELECTION.
OBVIOUSLY IN THE MIDTERMS.
AND REPUBLICANS ARE ALL EXCITED
ABOUT THE ONE THING THEY WILL
DELIVER.
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE STRANGELY
CONTENT AND SELF-CONFIDENT.
WHY?
HERE'S ONE THEORY UNPROVEN OF
COURSE, JUST THROWING IT OUT
THERE TO THINK ABOUT.
DEFENSE SECRETARY LLOYD AUSTIN
ANNOUNCED THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS EVACUATED
125,000 CIVILIANS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
ONLY 6,000 OF THEM, LLOYD AUSTIN
TOLD US OUR AMERICAN PUT THE
REST ARE AFGHANS.
OF THOSE, VERY FEW OF THE
AFGHANS WERE TRANSLATORS, AIDES,
THE ALLIES WE ARE HEARING SO
MUCH ABOUT THAT FOUGHT WITH THE
U.S. MILITARY AND DESERVE OUR
SUPPORT.
OF THAT GROUP, THEY ARE ONLY A
FEW THOUSAND.
YOU CAN BE SURE OF THIS FROM A
LOT OF DIFFERENT SIGNS, BUT HERE
IS ONE SIGN.
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT IN
ALEXANDRIA, VIRGINIA, A VERY
LIBERAL TOWN TAKING THOUSANDS OF
HELP REFUGEES.
AND THEY PUT OUT THIS REQUEST
"ALEXANDRIA HEALTH DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING FOR POSTERITY SPEAKERS
TO ASSIST WITH TRANSLATION
SUPPORT TO RECENT ARRIVALS."
SO THE ONE THING WE KNOW ABOUT
THESE RECENT ARRIVALS IS THEY
ARE NOT TRANSLATORS, BECAUSE
TRANSLATORS PROBABLY WOULD NOT
NEED TRANSLATORS.
THESE ARE INSTEAD REFUGEES WHO
DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHERE ARE
THEY GOING NEXT?
WHERE WILL THESE PEOPLE BE
LIVING THREE YEARS FROM NOW?
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION AND YOU
CAN TELL IT IS A HIGHLY RELEVANT
QUESTION, BECAUSE WHENEVER YOU
ASK IT, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SERVANTS AND THE NATIONAL NEWS
MEDIA SAYS THAT YOU ARE A RACIST
AND YOU NEED TO SHUT UP
IMMEDIATELY.
>> THEY ARE GETTING CAUGHT UP IN
WHAT I CALLED THE BROWN MENACE
WHICH IS THE RIGHT WING FEAR OF
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE COUNTRY
FROM CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA,
THEY NEED TO -- SEEM TO BE
GETTING SWEPT UP IN XENOPHOBIA.
>> TO THE COLLAPSE OF
AFGHANISTAN, THE TAKEOVER OF THE
TALIBAN, LOOK AT JOE BIDEN, HE
IS TRYING TO GET BROWN PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY.
IT'S SICKENING AND PATHETIC.
>> Tucker: AS WE TOLD YOU
BEFORE, THE ON THE RIGHT HIT
THAT FROM JOE MAR ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
AND BEGGING THE STATE DEPARTMENT
TO PLEASE SEND 125,000 AFGHAN
REFUGEES, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
THERE ARE OPEN MINDED.
CLEARLY THEY ARE.
HOW MANY REFUGEES DO YOU THINK
ARE GOING TO WIND UP IN SHOW
MAR?
RIGHT AROUND ZERO.
THE FUNNIEST PART IS WHEN THOSE
TWO CHARACTERS DESCRIBE THEM AS
BROWN PEOPLE, THAT'S HILARIOUS,
BECAUSE FOR THE RECORD, THEY ARE
NOT BROWN, THEY ARE WHITER THAN
YOU ARE, BUT THAT'S NOT THE
POINT.
CNN ONCE YOU DO KNOW THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW HOW
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING
HERE FROM AFGHANISTAN AND WHERE
THEY ARE GOING.
WHAT NEIGHBORHOODS ARE THEY
GOING?
BUT OF COURSE YOU HAVE A RIGHT,
BECAUSE IT IS YOUR COUNTRY.
YOU OWN IT, YOU PAY FOR IT, YOU
WERE BORN HERE.
IT BELONGS TO YOU.
SO YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN YOUR COUNTRY, WE
LOOKED INTO IT, BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE ARE PAID TO DO.
SO IF YOU GO ONLINE RECENTLY AND
LOOK AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OWNED BY TONY BLINKEN, YOU WILL
FIND A LIST OF WHAT THEY CALL
WELCOMING COMMUNITIES WHERE
AFGHAN REFUGEES IN PARTICULAR
VISA HOLDERS WILL BE SETTLING IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THAT LIST
LONG ENOUGH, YOU MAY NOTICE
SOMETHING, ESPECIALLY THE
GOVERNMENT POLICY, YOU NOTICE
THAT THESE COMMUNITIES INCLUDE A
LOT OF SWING DISTRICTS AND SWING
STATES ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT JUST VIRGINIA.
THREE OF THESE COMMUNITIES ARE
IN TEXAS, THE STATE THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS TRIED TO
ECLIPSE FOR YEARS NOW.
THEIR FIRST PRIORITY.
ONE OF THESE CITIES IS ALLSTON.
THE OTHER IS DALLAS.
THE OTHER IS HOUSTON.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT URGED
AFGHANS TO GO TO PENNSYLVANIA.
DOES PENNSYLVANIA NEED MORE
PEOPLE?
PROBABLY NOT.
A LOT OF UNEMPLOYMENT BETWEEN
PITTSBURGH AND PHILADELPHIA,
PENNSYLVANIA IS ALSO A STATE
THAT DONALD TRUMP WON IN 2016,
SO MAYBE THEY SHOULD GO THERE,
FLORIDA, ATLANTA, GEORGIA,
NEVADA, COLORADO, ALSO ON THE
LIST.
ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THIS?
FUNNY, ONE SWING STATE IS NOT ON
THE OFFICIAL LIST AS WISCONSIN,
BUT THEY ARE GETTING A LOT OF
REFUGEES FROM AFGHANISTAN TOO.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN PUBLICLY
ANNOUNCED, WE LEARN ON MONDAY
WHEN TIM TIFFANY JOINED US TO
DESCRIBE HIS VISIT TO THE
FORT McCOY AND THE STATE OF
WISCONSIN.
HE SAID OF THE 2,000 AFGHAN
NATIONALS THEY ARE, NONE WERE
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA HOLDERS.
NONE HAD WORKED FOR THE U.S.
MILITARY.
AND NONE OF THEM WERE "ALLIES"
THE PEOPLE TO WHOM WE OWE FREE
HEALTH CARE.
HE ALSO SAID THAT THESE AFGHANS,
DESPITE NOT BEING ALLIES WERE
FREE TO WALK OFF THE BASE ANY
TIME INTO OUR COUNTRY.
AND JUST MOVE HERE.
WHATEVER?
NO PAPERWORK FOR THEM, NOBODY
WAS STOPPING THEM.
AND THERE ARE A LOT TO -- ABOUT
TO BE A LOT MORE PEOPLE LIKE
THIS AT THE BASE.
COURT McCOY IS ASKED TO HOLD
UP TO 13,000 AFGHANS.
THE GOVERNOR OF WISCONSIN AWARE
OF THIS?
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE OF WISCONSIN
THINK ABOUT A QUESTION MARK
NOBODY CARES WHAT THEY THINK, IT
IS NOT THE COUNTRY.
OH, BUT IT IS.
AND YOU SHOULD BE NERVOUS
WATCHING.
IN A TRULY DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM OF
FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY, THE
PEOPLE WHO WRECKED AFGHANISTAN
AND HUMILIATED THE UNITED STATES
AND SACKED AMERICA POWER FOREVER
WILL BE PUNISHED BADLY IN THE
MIDTERMS.
THEY WOULD TO LOSE THE POWER
OVER THIS.
THEY WOULD BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
APPEARED AND THEY KNOW THAT.
SO THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN TO AVOID AN ELECTION
THEY WILL LOSE.
THEY ARE FLOODING SWING
DISTRICTS WITH REFUGEES THEY
KNOW WILL BECOME LOYAL
DEMOCRATIC PARTY VOTERS.
THEY ARE OPENING THE SOUTHERN
BORDERED IN MORE THAN 200,000
LEGAL MIGRANTS PER MONTH.
THAT'S THE EQUIVALENT OF TWO
AFGHAN AIR LIFTS EVERY 30 DAYS.
AND ABOVE ALL, THEY ARE USING
COVID TO CHANGE HOW WE VOTE.
THESE ARE THE TOOLS THAT THEY
ARE USING TO MAINTAIN POWER.
TO MAINTAIN POWER, LET'S BE
CLEAR, LET'S NEVER FORGET HAS
ALWAYS BEEN AND HAS ALWAYS --
AND ALWAYS WILL BE THEIR GOAL.
AND YOU SEE THE RESPECTED HEALTH
AUTHORITY FIGHTING MALARIA TO
THE GOOD JOB OF THAT.
NOW SEEMS TO BE IN CHARGE OF
HOUSING POLICY IS PAID REMEMBER
WHEN MICHELLE WILENSKY DENIED A
SUPREME COURT RULING TO TELL YOU
YOU CAN EVICT PEOPLE FOR ANY
REASON EVEN IF THEY ARE NOT
PAYING RENT?
ONCE SHE GOT UP AND FIRED FOR
THAT, SHE DID NOT APOLOGIZE,
DESECRATING THE CONSTITUTION AND
MOCKING THE SUPREME COURT, NO,
INSTEAD THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAS GIVEN HER MORE POWER WHICH
SHE NOW HAS.
WATCH AS SHE TELLS YOU YOU
SHOULD PROBABLY NOT TRAVEL FOR
THE HOLIDAY WEEKEND EVEN THOUGH
YOU HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
>> WE HAVE ARTICULATED THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE FULLY
VACCINATED, AND WHO ARE WEARING
MASKS CAN TRAVEL, ALTHOUGH GIVEN
WHERE WE ARE WITH THE NEW
TRANSMISSION RIGHT NOW, WE WOULD
SAY THAT PEOPLE NEED TO TAKE
THESE RISKS INTO THEIR OWN
CONSIDERATION AS THEY THINK
ABOUT TRAVELING.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, IF YOU ARE
UNVACCINATED, WE RECOMMEND NOT
TRAVELING.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO THIS IS A
PARTISAN DEMOCRAT FOR WHOM THE
CONCERNS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ARE NEVER FAR FROM MINE.
SO YOU HAVE TO THINK OF IT
THROUGH A POLITICAL LENS,
BECAUSE TRUST US, THEY DO.
WHY ARE THEY MAKING YOU MORE
FEARFUL THEN YOU NECESSARILY
NEED TO BE?
SOME PEOPLE SHOULD BE VERY
AFRAID OF COVID, BUT NOT
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
WELL MAYBE, IT'S FOR THE SAME
REASON THEY WOULD LIKE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF AFGHANS TO FLOOD
THE SWING STATES.
IT GIVES THEM THE POWER TO
CHANGE THE RULES OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SO THAT THEY DON'T
LOSE THEIR ELECTION PAIRED
CONSIDERING WHAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA'S RECALL
ELECTION WHICH IS TWO WEEKS FROM
TODAY.
IN FEBRUARY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN CALIFORNIA PASSED
A LAW REQUIRING THAT ALL
REGISTERED VOTERS GET A MAIL-IN
BALLOT EVEN IF THEY DID NOT ASK
FOR A MAIL-IN BALLOT.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
COVID OF COURSE.
"THE PANDEMIC HAS NOT GONE AWAY"
SAID ONE TELEPHONE AT
CONGRESSMAN.
THAT IS CONVENIENT FOR THEM AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR GAVIN NEWSOM
WHO KNOWS THAT MAIL-IN BALLOTS
WOULD BY DEFINITION LACK ANY
FORM OF VOTER I.D. CANNOT BE
VERIFIED.
THOSE KIND OF BALLOTS OPENLY
BENEFIT HIS PARTY BECAUSE THEY
EVENT TO VOTER FRAUD.
IN CONNECTICUT, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ALLOWING
ANYONE TO VOTE ABSENTEE AS LONG
AS THEY SAY THEY ARE AFRAID OF
GETTING SICK.
"ANYONE WHO IS AFRAID OF
CONTRACTING COVID OR EXPECT THEY
WILL BE SICK ONCE IT IS
ANNOUNCED IS INTENDED TO A
MAIL-IN BALLOT."
THESE ORDERS CAME FROM THE STATE
SECRETARY OF STATE WHO IS AT A
PARTISAN DEMOCRAT.
THE MEDIA OUTLET SAID THAT IT
GETS THE BOATING SYSTEM ELECTED
TO BECOME PERMANENT NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS WITH COVID.
SO THIS ISN'T ABOUT PUBLIC
HEALTH, THIS IS ABOUT ELECTIONS.
IF IT WAS ABOUT PUBLIC HEALTH,
THEY WOULD BE TELLING YOU TO
LOSE WEIGHT, BUT THEY ARE NOT.
THIS IS ABOUT ELECTIONS.
BUT WHATEVER YOU DO, DON'T
NOTICE THAT, THE QUESTIONS WITH
THE THOUSANDS OF AFGHANS THAT
HAVE NOT BEEN VETTED.
WE ARE QUOTING NOW, I CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT NO ONE IS COMING INTO
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WHO
HAS NOT BEEN THROUGH A THOROUGH
SCREENING AND BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS.
THAT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN'S PRESS
SECRETARY SAID JUST TODAY.
BUT IT IS A LIE.
MEANWHILE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF UNIDENTIFIED ILLEGAL ALIENS
STREAM ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER EVERY MONTH.
WHO ARE THESE PEOPLE?
WE DON'T KNOW.
WE CAN'T KNOW.
IN A FUNCTIONING DEMOCRACY, THIS
WOULDN'T WORK.
VOTERS WOULDN'T PUT UP WITH IT.
EVEN PARTISAN DEMOCRATS WOULD
SAY, COME ON NOW.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A BORDER.
IT'S A COUNTRY.
SO WE START BEHAVING THIS WAY,
SO OUTSIDE THE BOUNDS OF NORMAL
BEHAVIOR, SO FAR FROM WHERE THE
POPULATION ACTUALLY WANTS,
CLEARLY YOU DON'T PLAN TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE AT THE
ELECTION.
YOU PLAN TO CHANGE THE WAY T